say thank to
both katie simone and the organizer for
this very beautiful conference i really
enjoyed it
and i'm also very happy and grateful to
to talk here today
all right so i will i will present a
work in collaboration with my
phd advisor yamas
and
eva and peter to
three people in in bonn as well
so we talk about discrete to continue
limits of dynamical optimal transport
and i can show you actually here what is
the outline of the talk so i will
introduce
um
let's say the general setting and it
continues in continuous problems
and and then i will move to the disco
setting so discuss about how to make uh
this continuous problem to the discrete
one
and then uh i will discuss precisely the
descriptor continuing limit in the
setting of of periodic graphs
and during the talk and at the end like
a bit in between i will just try to give
you some examples and possible
applications of this result
all right so um
about decepting at the continuous level
um
i think we have seen enough time
uh vessels and two distances during this
workshop and dynamical formulation so i
just put one slide
just to recall that
as a starting point
is the dynamical perspective of optimal
transport
which in in the specific case of ascent
really means to minimize the total
kinetic energy between all the possible
solution of the continuity equation so
all the possible evolution
of of the mass
so of course this is just the case of
ascend too what i'm interested in is
essentially the same type of problems uh
but a bit more generally so where
instead of looking at the kinetic energy
in in this in this part here i'm
interested in a bit more general setting
where just consider
a given convex function all right so in
this case f is just some convex lower
semicontinuous function of
the mass and the momentum so i also did
this change of variable i would always
work with mass and momentum
to make the problem convex
and aside that is essentially the same
problem as before but the function f can
just model different situations
so let me just give you some examples so
again the this the equality choice with
respect to the flux
variable is the one corresponding to a
center
and
but of course you can consider also more
general situations especially for vases
and b of course you can always consider
homogeneous cases but you can also inc
includes in your model some
non-linearity dependence on the mass we
actually seen this exactly in the talk
of the manuela this morning
this can allow to consider in the model
some crowd effect
for example could be that the velocity
of my motion is not really independent
on the other particles
but if i have more particles for example
i can have a slow down velocity in the
motion and this can be modeled by this
no linear
dependence on the mass here
so of course this is the same type with
the different choice of the function f
and then also one let's say i think more
say easier
uh setting is the one of the the things
i would call the flow based problems
which there where the cost depends only
on the flux variable
so in this case actually the picture is
easier because we don't have any
dependence on the mass in the problem so
actually this dynamical formulation can
be also reduced every time to a static
formulation because in fact you can see
just by inequality that the cheapest
choice of the flux is to just be
constant in time
all right so because of the of the
convexity of the function so the
averaging time will always be the
optimizers in the problem so in fact i
can integrate in time this equation and
get this started formulation here
in sort of like bregman type of
divergence
and this includes for example less than
one but also like negative solved
distances and different different
problems
all right so the motivations about
working on on this general setting is uh
is of course i said optimal transport
and also the study of other type of
evolution like traffic flows congested
transport and so on
and we've seen during this conference
many times that there is a nice
connection between grading flows and
optimum transport and this was actually
possible through this dynamical
interpretation of the distance
i'm not sure about it i think nobody
actually said something about another
connection
with another part of mathematics during
this conference which is this connection
uh with some remaining geometrical
properties of the manifolds so when you
are working on a manifold there is a
very nice connection between for example
positive curvature condition on the
manifold with respect to some properties
of for example the entropy
along the geodesics of assassin 2.
so this will not be the focus of my talk
what i want to say here is that there
are some very nice connections which is
not only
modeling of the problem which which
somehow was
possible only through this dynamical
interpretation
and so what actually happened in 2011
when milk
and mass worked on a discrete optical
transport was exactly to try to
generalize not only the definition of
the transport but also to try to recover
the same type of structure we have
at the continuous level so gradient
flows richer curvature and so on
all right so let me
introduce you to the discretonal
transporter and now we start with the
quadratic case so the original work of
of jan and milke
so what is the setting for me when i say
discrete so we should just always keep
in mind this is going to be like a
weighted graph
so x is just a set of vertices e are
those green connections so the edges
and omega is a weight
on the graph
probably something that antonio and deja
would have called eta
some days ago
all right and once we have this this
setting what we want to do is to define
a discrete distance
over the graph
and intuitively you just simply do it by
taking the dynamical formulation and
discretize in some suitable way
and actually we've seen already this
formulation i think uh in the talk of
antoine deion
uh the natural way to do it is to take a
discrete continuity equation where
instead of the continuous divergence we
have a discrete divergence
here i'm not assuming any skew symmetry
on the flux so i'm just writing this
difference here and then the action will
be defined in some sort of natural
discretization of the continuous one
where we have this
kind of strange situation where we need
to take an average of the density
because we don't really have a density
defined over the edges so we need to
choose
this function theta
and and already advertised in previous
talk the choice that they made in these
papers what the logarithmic mean
that somehow was the right choice to
recover all the continuous theory also
in the discrete space
so in particular what they do is they
choose this specific choice of the
average which is probably not the first
one one would have in mind
and in this way they get the same
structure so if we take the gradient
flow of the discrete entropy
uh we end up with this so-called graph
heat flow
so the graphical flow is just when you
take the discrete laplacian
where the laplacian is just obtained in
the following way you can see many also
probabilistic perspective it's just a
markov
process continuous macro process where
the rate
of jumping is given exactly by like this
these guys there
all right so
what i want to do is to to to discuss
about some discrete quantum
approximation results
actually this is part of two papers the
first one uh was a one dimensional
result where we first tried to
understand what the general situation
was and then we found out
that although with very different
techniques the result was way more
general and then we actually managed to
do this in a bit more
quite more general situation in high
dimension and for any energy
and actually this literally appeared
today so i'm very happy because i was
running running running trying to to
make this happening before the
conference it really happened few hours
ago so
that's pretty nice
all right so
before describing the exact setup let me
just make some literature
so what is this to continue so what was
the first result in this setting so the
first one that i'm aware of is the work
of uh julia moss in 2013.
so they proved that if you take the the
continuous stores in every dimension and
you take the easiest discretization you
have in mind when you just take the grid
so you just take the square with the
and you just discretize with this
squares of size one over n
then you can just define a graph
structure very intuitively by taking the
center of the cubes and nearest
neighbor's interactions group of
connections
and then you can consider the
corresponding distance and what they
proved is that
the discrete distance converges to the
continuous one when you take and goes to
plus infinity so when the then the graph
is getting denser and denser
this was the first result deterministic
so no randomness just specific type of
partitions and then nicolas i think
actually this is the year of publication
but i think he proved this even i think
2017 18.
he provided another approximation result
descriptive to continuum
but in a random setting so where instead
of taking a precise deterministic
partition you just throw id points
on on on the torus
and then you define an edge between the
points if the points are close enough
together
uh it's a very beautiful result the
setup is very different not only because
it's random but because of this
diverging degree situation so actually
the points are seen a lot of neighbors
it goes to plus infinity when n goes to
plus infinity which is very different
from this setup we only have 2d networks
in some sense
so after this works essentially the
point was all right we have these
approximation results the problem is
especially the first example is very
structured so it's very symmetric and
the question could be
can we do something more than just the
simple grid
and what they actually proved in uh
last year three years ago actually
that it is not always true that the
distance converges to the continuous one
so if you take final volume partitions
essentially means you take a convex body
and you take just partitions in convex
cells
there is a natural graph structure you
can associate to this again by
taking
nearest neighbors of south
interaction
and they show that the convergence is
only true if you assume an additional
geometric assumption with they called
isotropic condition
i would not right here discuss here this
condition but at the end of the talk i
promise i will go back
to this setting i will show you what
doesn't mean in the periodic setting
with things a bit easier
to write it down
but there are situations like this where
you have the convergence
and in my opinion very stable situation
like very easy picture like this where
you don't have convergence
so this was essentially the starting
point of my phd
and
we were trying to understand whether we
can do something more so okay we have a
situation where the convergence appears
with a situation where we don't have
convergence so what happens when you
don't have convergence to bust into
um so the setting i want to describe is
the periodic setting where we try we
manage to give a full answer to this
question
so what do you mean with periodic graph
i mean the following we are for
simplicity let's say we are in our d
embedded energy and i just have a graph
which is locally finite so in each cube
i only see this final number of points
this is these blue dots
and also define a number of edges these
green arrows here are the one inside the
cube
and then it's if you just shift the
graph we get the same picture
which means that essentially all the
information on the graph is in this side
this cube
and all the edges pointing out from this
cube
so what i want to do is to study the
problem
i told you before but in the discrete
setting which means i don't really make
a choice of the function f i just take
some convex and local function f
local because i mean it could depend on
the whole graph but i want to to i'm
focusing in this in this problem which
is a bit different from some previous
songs into some local problems so i
really want the dependence only to be
for simplicity let's say inside the cube
but important thing is just that is
locally depending around the cube
and then i just minimize the action in
the same way where i have the discrete
continuity equation and not the
continuous
one and
maybe two feet also with the previous
stocks so a few days ago if you assume
jt should be exclusive metric you get
the the same all divergence
which is okay because the all the
optimizer actually is qc metric so
nothing change
all right so what i want to do is to
study this class of problems and let me
give you again a few examples
so
the example you might have in mind a
simple one is energies of this type
which i would call the edge base case
where you only have a sum
of some energies f x y
and then you just sum over all the edges
inside the cube inside the green cube
and if you choose special type of
energies like this one the quadratic
choices
you get exactly this
mass milky type of discretization of the
graph
here i even brought this
concave dependence here because if you
want to approximate this generalized
last and distance we can do the same
we just need to plugged in in this case
setting
and exactly like before the flow base
means when you don't have a dependence
on
on the mass and again you get the static
formulation
even in the discard setting instead of
the continuous divergence we have the
discrete divergence
all right so
what do i want to do i want to
approximate to study the limit as the
mesh gets finer and finer
so what i want to do is to say this
graph and the problem and i want to
rescale it
so when i say rescale i think the
following
so
this uh
right cube is the same one as in the
left hand side i just zoomed in to be to
see a bit a bit easier and if i rescape
by a parameter epsilon on the graph
i get a lot of copies
of the same graph but smaller inside the
cube
so for if i just
multiply by this epsilon the graph i get
a lot of copies so my graph inside the
cube
and then what i want to do is i want to
rescale the energy and how do i want to
define the rescale energy i want to say
well i take the energy of each of these
small cubes
and then i take an average of all these
contributions
of course i also have to scale the mass
and the flux if i want to see something
local in the limit and the nice scaling
in this case the right scaling is to
divide the mass by epsilon to the power
d
and to
divide the flux by d epsilon d minus one
because in fact the flux you should
think of of the flux as a flux over a
surface so you should really rescale
this
by a surface type of term here
this means this minus that this means
i'm centering the problem on this cube
and then i'm taking the average over all
the cubes
it's just a natural rescaling of the
problem if i have a density graph
when i rescale and so what we can do in
this situation i want to study the limit
as epsilon goes to zero
so when epsilon goes to zero we can
prove the following thing so
and we can do this in high dimension in
any dimension and for any f essentially
i wrote here this
uh superlinear growth condition in fact
just for simplicity of the presentation
i think also they and last time said
that when you don't have
good growth condition you might have
problems of singular parts of the
measure and things like this so let's
say in this case we don't have this
problem
and
what we are able to prove is that as
epsilon goes to zero
the discrete cost converges to a
continuous one
which is exactly of the same type of the
one i showed you at the beginning
so it's a minimization like a bena
mubrine type of formula
where the cost is given by this half
home
so there are two layers of of let's say
or results here so one thing is that we
have a limit
and the second thing is that not only we
know that the limit is of this form but
we can say something way more specific
about the limited form
so we can compute essentially explicit
the form as a function of f the one we
started from at the discrete level
and the graph we had at the beginning
and i will show you some examples
so the d equal one case for the
quadratic choice of the energies was
uh the first contribution it was very
different i mean it was obtained with
some techniques which are very typical
of the quality case
and of of dimension one
and in fact in high dimension we can do
something more not really so important
on this level we can really prove gamma
convergence of the
functional defined on the space of
curves
so when you take optimal transfer here
you're taking the minimal
this let's say kinetic energy between
all the curves
in fact what we can prove is really
gamma convergence of the function
defines on the space of curves and then
as a consequence you get actually
convergence of the disk of of this cost
oh all right so i promise i have this
formula for for a form so i wish i would
try to explain to you how to compute the
limit
so let me just give some notation so we
have this original graph so before any
rescaling
and then i would just define the norm of
m as the mass in the cube so let's say
the sum of the mass in these three
points
and then here we see actually something
we've seen i think in day and talk so
for every vector in rd i define the
effective flux which is a discrete
object i mean it's a it's still in rd
but is somehow um managing to pass from
discrete to continuum so j is a discrete
vector flux and then i just take the sum
of the flux over all these green errors
where d x y is the flux and y minus x is
just the direction of the edge
so the this guy is somehow able to
for any discrete vector fields to define
a continuous j they really should play
the role of the continuous flux at a
continuous level and i will show you
actually a precise example
and so if this notation is in in the
game then we can really compute the form
in the following way so we fix any
rowing psi
so rho is just a number and psi is a
vector
and then i do the following thing i take
between all the possible mj on the cube
all the possible way to put the mass and
the flux on the cube i want to take the
one that minimizes the discrete cost
with some constraints and the constraint
is that the total mass has to be equal
to raw
the first variable the total flux has to
be equal to psi
and the discrete divergence equal to
zero
so every time you give me an f and a
graph i can compute this guy for every
rowing psi
and this will be really like the
continuous energy density that defines
the problems in the limit
so i don't know how much time i have i
think like
about nine minutes right so i will maybe
i think it's constructive and for me it
was constructed to try to see at least
one example about construction a
competitor for this uh formula so
suppose we fix in dimension two because
well we only have dimension two
available here uh rho equal to phi and
psi equal to two three
so the first constraint says that i need
to find a way to put the mass in these
blue dots
in such a way the total mass is five we
can do this in a very
easy way in many different ways let's
say for example we say three here one
here and one here
so this would be a competitor for the
mass
and because this this guy at least for
me at the beginning was a bit mysterious
in fact when you want to find a j here
on the green
arrows such that the effective flux is
equal to 2 3 this really means
that the horizontal flux from the cube
outside
the horizontal one should be equal to 2
and the vertical one has to be equal to
three
i don't really care what happens here
you can actually prove it is invariant
by
shuffling the points inside because we
have dimensions zero so the only thing
that matters are what happens here
and here
so an example would be the following so
you have
these
values on on the arrows for example
and if you see how much flux is going
outside is this number two
which is why because we need to have
this uh competitor here and if you look
at the vertical displacement outside
from inside outside the cubes i have
four going out
and one getting in so it's about four
minus one we get exactly these three
it's not trivial to c but whatever
happens inside here is not really
important because of this divergent zero
condition
so whenever you want to find a
competitor what you really need to do is
just shuffle things inside and be sure
that the flux at the boundary is the
right one
all right so i just want to conclude
with some let's say the application we
had in mind actually the one we started
from
there was this final volume situation
so what happens in in that case is the
following so final volume i mean exactly
what i was saying at the beginning
uh but of course i wanted to be periodic
to try to apply a result
which means i just take a partition of
the cube
and i rescale it and then copy again in
the cube
this gives me like a random
a periodic graph
just again i just say the two cells are
connected by an edge if they have a
common interface
and then there is a particular choice of
the weights which i would not comment
too much
is this geometric choice it's very
typical already in the numerical
analysis community when they wanted to
find a volume approximation of pdes this
is the right choice of the weights for
some scaling reason
and
so in this particular case for this
special type of energy so the vast and
two type of the
of cost
so we can we can really say something
more so of course for one dimensional
what we get in this case is the
following so the limit
will be a multiple of us and two
so remember at the beginning i told you
if you're symmetric you get less than
two if you're not you don't guess less
than two so what we can do here is to
say okay we still get something
which is explicit and it's a multiple of
us and two
where the multiple is exactly given by
this form one one
is always cheaper but it can be strictly
cheaper so you don't always get busting
too
and in the multidimensional case you get
the following general result this says
okay we still get something of this form
like in the general setting
but we can say something more something
somehow peculiar happens is that we all
will have a sort of assessment too
with respect to a norm
which i called here home norm home
homogeneous homogenized norm
but this norm does not need to be equal
to the euclidean one so you always get
vast entry in the limit but it might
happen that this norm is actually
something which is not even induced by a
scalar product
it could be something since layering in
some sense so not even remaining
structure in the limit
you get the equality with busting two so
you get that this norm is equal to the
euclidean one
if and only if you have this orthopedic
condition
like recovering what happens what they
might collaborate approved in their
first result
okay and then i just conclude with the
promised picture
and this uh what does isotropic
condition means
so the first time i saw it i was a bit
puzzled and confused so this is the
algebraic condition so we say that a
partition is isotropic if for every node
x
this equality between matrices hold
where n of x y is the normal sorry the
normal between
the the interfaces normal on the
interface
and i mean honestly maybe you can give
me some more insight but when i saw this
equality at the level of the matrices i
didn't really get what this dramatic
interpretation would be
but you can actually do some drawing
especially in some nice setting and try
to understand what does this mean
so if you now evaluate this on some
vector field some vector b let's say on
the sphere
then this condition really means that
the measure of this red cube
is equal to the sum of these terms let's
say just focus on which i just obtained
by taking b here on the left-hand side
and in fact those terms have a geometric
interpretation and the dramatic
interpretation is that you can construct
a sort of dual partition so for every
edge
and every vector v i can construct this
rectangular
with the direction which is parallel and
orthogonal to v
and for every edge i have one of those
rectangular so for example i have one
two three four edges and four
rectangulars and of course if i change v
this dual partition changes and what
this condition really means
is that the total sum
the area of this gray era here so if i
sum the volume of these guys i get
exactly twice the area of the cube
and
i wasn't sure about this even in this
very structural case but you can
convince yourself but just moving the
hands a bit that
really the total area of these guys is
twice as much of the cube by just moving
around pieces missing and
and playing a bit
so if you have isotropic condition you
get the convergence if you don't have it
you just
convert to something which is not passed
into
all right and then i just conclude
telling you that uh there might be some
personally from interesting problems
uh to go
from from this result on which is
uh we actually wanted to try to
understand the distance to then try to
study the convergence of the flows for
example so we know that every time we
have a distance
uh we can try also to look at the
gradient flows corresponding and try to
study the convergence
and then i would also be very interested
to uh to discuss some more random
setting like the one of nicolas in a bit
more general situation uh
in in this picture
all right and
i thank you for for your attention
thank you very much
any questions
yes
listen
so
thank you
so
for
connected to the
you know to these uh
randomness but more in the spirit of
um
what nicolas did so
do you think that so because in this
case uh as you said the you know the
interaction is very local right right
yes from so if you replace it by a
non-local which is still it is going to
zero you expect that you still
you recover some you recover you will
recover w2 as soon as you are
just a bit non-local so you have
infinite degree or there is a scaling it
between which might depend on the
geometry or something like that
okay um that's that's very interesting i
mean of course depends what we mean with
non-local in the sense that
i mean of course i'm not completely sure
but the number of of connecting edges
and being local might be different right
because i can just have a very very
dense graph
and still have a sort of bounded range
of connectivity
i was thinking precisely your graph
right but instead of being connected
just to the neighbors being connecting
with
so enlarging a big use
you mean for the final volume or in
general because in general it is not
only nearest neighbors so i mean if you
go here i mean i draw a picture like
this but in fact this just for
simplicity i'm completely allowed in our
result to get a connection from this guy
to
verify one
but a degree is always fixed because
it's periodic i agree yes
all right
i don't know i think might be still
playing some role this this
this problem of the lack of
symmetry um
yeah i might i might i still have the
feeling that this image of the problem
could still be a problem in some sense
but
uh yeah it's very interesting
thank you lorraine it's a nice talk
i'm a little bit confused about the
isotropic condition
so
i was trying to understand
whether
one could reformulate this condition
at the level of the equation
which question so the continued equation
there all right so
because so what does isotropic means
means that so basically the flow does
not depend on the direction more or less
right
yeah well it should really mean somehow
that there's no some privileged
directions you should take
right okay that's whatever because this
is really independence of v this means
that this situation happens so even if
you rotate the problem
um
it could be that you know someone i
don't know for instance taking like some
[Music]
momentum
radially symmetric whatever this means
well i mean i don't i don't know i think
well that you can see here so i don't
know in general if you if you ignore the
condition
you get this whatever this is actually
because it's not explicit
but it's a norm and then i think it's
really about
choosing the the say the cheapest
direction
but i don't really
i can't really say much more explicit
than this when you don't have the
symmetry
yeah but it's very very strange in some
sense
you know it was just an eye yeah i know
i get it yeah i will think about it
thank you thank you very much uh
actually i was also confused about that
i thought to be have some thought but
yeah being discussed of course it would
be very nice yeah thank you very much
our last speaker
for the workshop